the crab feeder is backed by powerful
entities within the free cities who wish
to see westeros weakened
and the king's failures have allowed him
to accumulate strength
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video in this
video i want to go over some interesting
information about the crab feeder from
house of the dragon
during a recent interview the actor
revealed some interesting information
about his character that you wouldn't
know from only watching the show let me
show you what he said when he sat down
with entertainment weekly for his
interview the headline reads house of
the dragon actor digs up secrets of
crackastra horror yes that is greyscale
on his arm and yes that is the mask you
think it is fire and blood george r
martin's compendium of targaryen history
that inspired hbo's house of the dragon
makes little mention of kraghashtrahar
the mirish prince admiral known by his
foes as the crab feeder what we know
about this figure as chronicled in the
novel's passage titled heirs of the
dragon a question of succession doesn't
even fill an entire page so as with
other story elements to house of the
dragon the makers of the tv series
decided to expand the scope of this
character the actor said he's a nasty
character so as an actor it's a dream
scott smith who's had smaller roles in
men in black international and dune says
over zoom from the uk it's nice when you
have details as well but it's also nice
when it's a completely open book
that gave us the freedom to do what we
wanted with the character which on a
creative level was incredible for me and
i think for the directors as well
because we could play around with it and
build our own version of crab feeder
fire and blood tells us that crack has
commanded the armies and fleet of the
triarchy which was the alliance of three
of the free cities across the narrow sea
lis mir and tyrosh it was under his
watch that these forces laid claim to
the stepstones an important trade route
between westerosi and essos but he
became greedy and demanded high tolls
from ships in exchange for safe passage
sometimes those tolls included human
trafficking crackhass was nicknamed crab
feeder for his unique way of doing away
with pirates staking them in the sand on
the beach of the stepstones and letting
the crabs eat away at them until the
tides came in actor scott smith
confirmed some of the newer aspects to
crackhass as seen in house of the dragon
first yes that is greyscale on his left
arm crackhash drahara is seen as the bad
guy but for any bad character there's
always going to be a journey of how they
got there after discussions with the
director of the second and third episode
they began unpacking the character so we
discussed the idea of him being a prince
or that he calls himself a prince so he
came from some sort of higher house we
spoke about that in the gradual decline
to where he is now how the grayscale
might affect him physically and even
mentally
i've seen greyscale before
nothing like that
i suppose that's why they send them
there
be kinder to put daggers in their hearts
and be done with it
the hair makeup and the prosthetics team
added further details to the skin around
the grayscale to make it look even more
raw we wanted to show the more prince
royal side but then we also wanted to
show the more feral side which came
through when he holds the hammer
the crab feeder is backed by powerful
entities within the free cities who wish
to see westeros weakened
and the king's failures have allowed him
to accumulate strength
we wanted the idea of the hammer turning
him into more of a beastly character the
mask was also another big part of the
character scott smith confirms it's the
same kind of mask worn by the sons of
the harpy and marine and game of thrones
that was another aspect he discussed
with the director after landing the role
he recognized it from watching the
original show it was definitely a nod to
that for i guess the fans because it's
something familiar for them and we
discussed the idea of him being the
first one to wear the mask and it
becoming iconic and therefore it built
from that
i was busy learning who funds the sons
of the harpy some things you can't rush
he found out the good masters of astapor
and the wise masters of yonkai
with help from their friends in volantis
why is he wearing the mask how does he
feel about it it's a statement so he's
quite happy about wearing it as you all
know crack has his first glimpse in
episode 2. and then the final battle in
the war for the stepstone sees his
demise at the hands of daemon targaryen
another interesting thing is the crab
feeder doesn't speak nor does he remove
his mask but for those watchers who look
for details elements like the mask and
greyscale were meant to evoke visual
connections to the original show when
filming first began on house of the
dragon scott smith would arrive seven
hours before the cameras actually rolled
that way they could apply all the
necessary makeup and costuming including
a partial wig to evoke the decaying
character's last remaining wisp of air
and separate effects for a graying eye
the final shot we see of the crab feeder
is not of scott smith but that mold made
for him at the beginning of the season
damon drags his adversaries remains out
from the cave and on to the beach where
the forces of lord corliss velaryon are
clashing with the triarchy fire and
blood does show illustrations of daemon
decapitating crack ass's head but it
seems that too was changed for the show
actor scott smith said it was a weird
experience to gaze upon his own dead
body even if it was fake i don't think
many fans would experience that normally
but it was surreal he says so as you can
see he did reveal some interesting
information about the crab feeder some
of these things you never would have
known if you were only a watcher of the
show so i thought i would make this
video and let all of you know what he
had to say i thought this was
interesting myself let me know what all
of you think about this down below as
always i want to thank all of you for
watching the video i hope all of you
have a great day i will see you again
very soon
bye
the dance of dragons
a true telling by grand mr monken being
a history of the war of targaryen
succession between the princess frienera
and aegon second of his name that nearly
destroyed the realm
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again
[Music]
[Music]
you